all right hello everyone we are uh doing
open language design review part of our
incremental language development
uh series and we are talking about items
that were listed in past years on a list
of so-called low-hanging fruit
is obviously not as low hangy as it
might be because nobody's picked it in a
bunch of years but we're going to be
starting to look at we're looking at
more of these
I know exactly how long the fruit has
been on the tree
um all right let's take a look at some
of these
okay graphics multi-column
okay Brett you are here right yes
so this is your Pinterest view thing
right
okay so let me make a general comment
here
the whole idea of symbolically combining
graphics
you know Graphics grid is one sort of
example of that
but this notion of
you take graphics and you combine them
you know I think you've argued that you
have to do that from the inside out
rather than the outside in
I think in my use cases you know the
absolutely predominant cases in terms of
the way that I think about it is outside
in that is I've got a bunch of Graphics
they're in a list I want to partition
the list to make an array I want to do
this I want to do that okay the typical
workflow that I have is the first thing
I'm doing for exploratory purposes I
just want to make that array okay axes
don't line up this thing that thing the
other thing I don't really care what I
care about is that I I cannot I find
utterly unusable your multi-panel layout
thing I've never used it not once
okay the you know that's inside out type
way of doing this it's not the way I
think about things it's not the way you
know it no I mean I don't think that
I mean so for me inside out versus
outside in
mm-hmm
is
separate from that
which is that
and
I mean so the distinction for me is
you know grid versus Graphics grid
are different in some very fundamental
ways
yeah I think it's a different dimension
of Distinction I mean the thing that I'm
going to say which I think you're going
to say quickly is oh if you're doing it
outside in you don't get to align axes
you don't know enough about the plot by
the time you've got it as a blob to be
able to do the the finery you know the
detail
and I'm going to argue against that
right what's up that argument
um I mean so I don't think
you know I'm not saying that everything
has to be done through
you know
the plot layout goes to row whatever
type things
I mean there's obviously cases where
that won't work and can't work because
you want to combine plot with a parts
you know
you know I'm all in favor of
being able to have abstract Constructors
okay Brett I've got a very concrete idea
okay
this is a similar thing to being able
let's say you've got math formulas
okay and you want to put them along with
text on a line
okay what happens is those math formulas
expose a limited number sort of a small
API of things like here's my Baseline
here's my uh bottom of the bounding box
here's whatever else they expose the
here's my Axis right we've got these
different concepts and access a baseline
a you know a bounding box Edge
okay I'm going to argue that I think we
should have the same kind of thing for
graphics
that is and maybe we do have we probably
already have some of that we have some
of that yes right but to me if we did
that here's the way that that would work
just like you know I make a grid
okay I've got a bunch of numbers in it
first time I make a grid I just want the
freaking grid it doesn't look beautiful
then I say oh I want to line it up with
this Center that I want this left
aligned I want this right or right
aligned I come in again and I go and get
those details right
you know what I'm saying yep and I can
imagine doing exactly the same thing in
a graphics layout type setup where you
know I come in I get the basic picture
then I want to tweak it
and and some of that tweaking if I've
got a three by five array and it's got
these particular things in it some of
that tweaking is going to be specific to
that size of array and that content
and it's going to break if I
programmatically you know if I change it
to a 7 by 12 array of bar charts or
something right get what I'm saying so
so
to me
okay as I'm talking to you about this
I'm I'm you know this idea that a
graphic exposes a limit like like a
formula or a box object exposes a
limited number of alignment features
right because that's what you're
basically talking about when it's an
outside in thing what you care about for
those Graphics is various things about
alignment and sizing correct
so yes so I think what we should do is
is figure out how to expose a limited
number of parameters that are like
you've got a box it's got a bounding box
it's got an axis it's got a baseline
whatever else it's got right I don't
know what those concepts are yet they're
probably the axes is amazing as far as
the axes and the frame edges
for the most part fine fine well and
that that you know but there's probably
some labeling stuff you know I mean the
other thing that you know run you know
we run into as a complication
is sort of
you get into this cases where
you know the constraints perhaps lead
you to effectively determining what the
shape of a box in a particular location
is
yeah I understand but look uh yes you
understand but your favorite use cases
for these are array plots you don't like
it when we change the aspect ratio
you know where you know for something
like plot you know if it's not you know
whatever golden ratio it gets you know
adjusted to
you know
0.6 exactly or something
instead of 0.61 whatever
you know
that's not as big a deal
well I'm not quite understanding I mean
we've got okay look one of the important
things that gets us messed up all the
time is hanging labels okay what's an
example you've got a bunch of plots
they're more or less aligned except one
of them has a scientific notation label
and so it Goofs out
okay
now to me that would be resolved by
having this notion of A Frame Alignment
or a bounding box alignment you know
bounding box alignment includes the
labels Frame Alignment which might be
the default doesn't include the labels
and aligns the frames but not you know
so the labels hang out different
distances
um you know and again it's not even
clear
you know okay
you know probably you want the the
descender of the 10 to the six
to be lower than the descender of the
3.4 or something you know what I'm
saying
as in you want that the 10 to the 6 to
be pushed down so that's six so the the
bottom of the the frames are aligned
oh
okay
yes right
on the bottom Edge I was thinking on the
left Edge oh I'm sorry
yeah okay so I'm thinking that right
um
okay but look look to me and by the way
this might be rather easy to do and I
think we should look at it this concept
because we've already got the concept we
don't have anybody who knows about in
detail about the Box alignment story do
we
no I don't think so okay so
I think you should think about this and
bring this back to another meeting an
exposure mechanism for a set of
parameters for any graphic
and and you know let's say you've got a
ternary
you know one of those ternary plots okay
and where's its axis I don't know you
know one of them is you know it's off at
some weird angle right I know where one
of them is yeah so one of them is easy
and one is easy right but I mean
you know
we've got this is the point what we're
trying to do here is make a a standard
API
for graphics even though there are
different kinds of graphics
for which we have defined so that in
your case where we're aligning a bar
chart with a pie chart for example where
it isn't stupid
right so a pie chart has to Define an
axis even though it doesn't have a
particularly natural axis
mm-hmm
so that it can be aligned with a with a
bar chart which does have an axis
and maybe a pie chart has a center which
a you know bar chart does not and a bar
chart would have a sensible definition
of a center so for every plot doesn't
the pie chart have an access it's just
not displayed
Oh you mean if you put an axis in I mean
it's not an intelligent access but yeah
okay fair enough at that point I mean
okay so it does have some definition of
where the axis would be but I'm not sure
I I think when I use the term axis I'm
not sure that I mean the place where the
axes would go
am I making sense there might be cases
where the acts I I understand but I'm
not sure I I understand what it is
you're trying to say but I don't know
how one would Define that no I
understand so it's the it's the um
I don't know we could call it the key
axis I mean bad name but you know what
I'm saying let's say we've got a plot
that has four different x-axis because
it's using one of our modern you know
multi-axis kinds of things okay you know
how do we align that four axis thing
with a little bar chart that just has
its default frame
right now you could obsess about that
but we could just have a notion that is
you know here's what we should do we
should have an idea just like we do for
type setting alignment Arrow whatever
well I don't know I'm not sure the type
setting way of doing it is the best way
but perhaps what we do is we have this
notion of the alignment axis
okay the the horizontal and vertical
alignment axes let's say
we might need both top and bottom ones
and left and right ones okay so we have
the alignment yeah and then well this is
reminding me a lot of you know
like the guides that you have in a page
layout program
or yeah
that's you know work for aligning
multiple things
right well okay that's reasonable but
then so then what would happen is inside
the graphic
you would say alignment axes Arrow
and then we might have named things
like you know lowest Axis or you know
what I know that's a confusion of the
word you know
um or it might say you know it might
have a you know so there's a way of
defining what the alignment axis is
supposed to be so in other words okay so
okay if what we're saying is you're
going to make a grid of some kind it
might be this Pinterest like grid it
might be a um you know an ordinary Grid
it's some kind of grid and that grid
thing is going to pick up certain
alignment axes from its contents
okay like this one cares about the uh
horizontal alignment axes but it doesn't
clear about the vertical alignment axes
am I making sense right
it's okay so
so and maybe there needs to be a concept
Beyond alignment axis which is sort of
outer bounding box alignment in addition
to the alignment axis
okay the alignment access would be the
frames align here but then there's
another piece which is
just give me enough space
which could include padding give me this
much space around me okay there's one
thing to align and the other is how much
space do I need
do you get what I'm saying exactly and
so so I mean I think if those things
were provided as Graphics options
pretty Universal Graphics options a bit
like image size is a pretty Universal
Graphics option
then that would give us and and then for
each graphic it could have no one to it
ways of defining what the alignment axis
is for example if you have a
multi-access plot and those axes have
names or something it could use those
names it's it's what it's trying to do
is it's trying to expose
you know sort of it's like it's like a
biological cell exposing random you know
things on the cell surface or something
um it's trying to expose certain things
on the surface of the graphic so that
that graphic can be combined with other
Graphics but the method the the how it's
exposing it is its own internal business
because in the end all it's going to
return is basically here is the axis
here is the coordinates of this or
something of this axis that is the thing
that will be aligned with other things
does that make sense right
um this is a good idea by the way this
is a really question I mean I I will
give you the example that's going to be
problematic or that's going to
require more thoughts
right okay so
imagine you have two plots in a pie
chart yep
and the pie chart is in the top right
corner of a two by two grid
okay
okay
and so you have a plot to the left of
the pie chart you have a plot below the
pie charts
yep you know depending on you know
though so if you're doing alignment
you're sort of
in the vertical Direction
I think
you know you want the width of the pie
chart does in some to Quote Match the
plot below it
I know I'm telling you right two
parameters you've got a
um
well actually maybe the better way to do
it is to say axis alignment and Frame
Alignment
except it isn't really frame bounding I
mean it's
basically
the image range and the plot range
are the first two things that you want
to be able to control
yeah but I mean
I don't know what is image range well
okay do plot of
you know whatever with frame goes to
true
okay select it
so you care about those orange lines and
you care about the frame lines yep and
you care about the axis line
but much less than the frame edges well
it depends depends what you're doing I
mean it does depend on what you're doing
but it depends what you're doing you
might care about the axis but you might
not
right okay what's the point you're going
to make so the point I was going to make
is that
you know if you have a pie chart to the
right of that yep and another plot below
the pie charts yep I mean you may end up
in cases where you simultaneously are
saying I want you know the height of the
you know the diameter of the circle
up for the pie charts to match both the
height and the width of those plots okay
I understand the ASU yeah I understand
the issue
um okay I mean let's actually do this I
mean we could say here we've got this
we've got I mean what you're talking
about is this
and let's let's make this you know let's
say pie chart
just yeah two more plots
foreign
it's the same bug I've been telling you
about this bug repeatedly
okay why am I not selecting why am I not
able to select that but I am able to
select that
I mean in general you don't want to
select but I'm not sure why am I able to
select this it's selecting when it's
popping when the event handler is
triggering yeah well I think it's a bug
that I mean this should be consistent
okay so if you're saying that
determining the size of that
what I'm saying is I understand I
understand you can get constraints that
can't be satisfied I get it exactly
right obviously
yes but that's not a reason to throw the
whole thing out no I'm not throwing the
whole thing out I'm just
right so I mean I think what what has to
happen is
possibly if we really want to get fancy
about it we can have something that
defines a priority order for satisfying
constraints
okay in other words that could be one of
the
um you know alignment
constraint
priority order I mean not a good name
but but you get what I'm saying
or alternatively
um
you just have a list here yeah you'd
have a list of the different types of
constraints
so I mean to me
okay so what are the things you want to
align there's the outer boundary
true outer boundary
which is the image size boundary yep as
the the frame
and there's axes
anything else
probably but of lesser importance okay
now
frame and axes for example are both a
little bit complicated because there
might be multiple frames
there might be multiple axes like like
for example if I were to take that plot
and I would say
um you know framed or framed
of that plot
which frame are we talking about
aligning
see what I'm saying yes
um there's another thing you might want
to align another thing to align
another
is insets of various kinds
and you might want to align also
might want to
align scaled points in the OR scaled or
coordinate points in the graph
you know so zero zero matches up
everywhere yep
now
this notion of an alignment point
is sort of relevant to this I think
see what I'm saying I mean this is a
um I mean that corresponds to saying you
want zero zero to lie down your zero
zeros to line up essentially right
and you know in the case of grids we
have some special alignments like the
decimal points and so on yep
okay and so similarly here what I'm
thinking is you know some plot types
might have special alignments like you
might might want the equator to line up
on geoplots for instance
sure
obviously the equator is a straight line
yeah right yeah assuming they're both in
the same projection yeah yeah right
whatever right that was a bad example
probably but but I mean but so
what
okay once you will okay this is what is
exposed from inside the graphic as an
alignment as a guide so to speak
okay
the second question is
don't you need more than just the guy
don't you need both what aligns and what
bounds things because you could align
but then it could crash into something
right you see what I'm saying
yes there's no good having it in other
words if you align and if it could crash
into something
then you've got to push the thing you
know then then you've got to re-jigger
the whole display to avoid crashing
right I mean so in other words the the
objective is
you know uh
align what you should align
avoid crashing
and maybe we have an option that allows
crashing
you see what I'm saying
spacing skills to negative numbers
yeah well right
you know I can imagine a case where two
perfectly avoid crashing you'd have to
really you know mess with with things
but you have this giant array and
there's one little point or number that
would crash you say I just don't care
see what I'm saying
so okay so first thing is okay so you
define what needs to be aligned
and I'm pretty sure that that's just
vertical and horizontal alignments I
don't think there's any other I don't
think 45 degree alignment is interesting
do you agree do people agree
I think so
okay
so
and that means that essentially what
we're doing is everything is defined by
well okay so this is an interesting case
this this one here is an interesting
case because
it
it's not a grid
it's not a grid so so basically what
we're saying is the auto wrapper all
right so the outer wrapper
is either
you know it's a row a column a grid
or what you've got here a multi-column
Now isn't don't we have this
multi-column construct for
things in general
right so we have it but I think it
always generates something that's grid
like
right so we should generalize
multi-column
to not force a grid
I'm sorry I must have missed something
what what what are we what what does it
mean for multi-column that doesn't
worser grid
um like what this example is where
The Columns are defined
I see
now I don't actually know if the columns
are defined here I mean in other words
did did this
that one is 20 columns wide
okay but but but
these pieces are clearly connected to
each other I don't quite know how this
was assembled in other words did you say
what's in every column
I said what's in every column
well I mean it computes what's in every
column
okay but it does that by saying
because I mean clearly those things up
there are connected to each other right
and it's happy well I mean they're
connected to each other in what sense
well I mean I assume that in the
generation of this there were a bunch of
sublists and those were the first
elements of a bunch of sublists no
okay how did they end up this took a
flat list of things
why did those guys end up together
and it was okay so
starting from the top left corner
the first plot is is that big tall left
one yep
second one is the second big tall left
one
right oh
and then so we're reading across
basically if these were numbered it
would go the numbers would go across
they would go one two three four across
here and then they've got to whatever it
is 20 or something then 21 is down here
is that right
verse 21 21 is
uh let's call it
column 11 row two
y
because I'm trying to minimize the
overall height
I see so you're filling in like Tetris
or something I don't know what kind of
style you're filling in
where you have hung down least exactly
boy 20 years ago I had this whole scheme
of um
uh
for moving 6 000 books
that involved boxing them in a certain
way
and at the final moment when they were
being boxed somebody had the bright idea
that you could fit extra books in these
boxes
I'm sure the movers loved that
well no the problem would have move is
responsible for that but but that
scrambled all the books basically
because of because of this right so to
know where if we were to number these
what you're basically saying is the
arrangement of these things
to predict where item 31 will land is
non-trivial in this grid
whereas an ordinary Grid it's just like
well how many things across are there
it's 31 mod whatever it is yep right
so here it could be a kind of messy to
do that so this is relevant in a case
where what you're trying to do is just
display these things but order doesn't
matter
correct
okay and fortuitously this worked out
nicely
uh
Crystal on our live stream says reminds
them of the cell layout algorithms CLA
where you put weights on cells you want
to prioritize I don't know about that
sounds interesting
um
I mean you know we've also
I mean this whole
okay we might have the wrong people here
to really discuss this
um
uh
I don't know exactly what this is this
um oh I see oh I know what this okay I
understand this is for microprocessor
for circuit layout
ah
you know there might be some relevant
things there
where there are certain modules that
you're trying to lay out on a chip
but then then then they have additional
constraints because there's all kinds of
connection constr you know how do you
lay it out I mean that was what
simulated kneeling was first invented
for was doing those layouts and
minimizing wire lengths and so on
um
okay but I think what we're learning
here I mean this seems like a good thing
to have this seems like a useful thing I
don't know exactly what we call it can
we can we align it with can we can we
make it multi-column I think that's what
we need to investigate
you mean the you know can we extend the
existing multi-column too yes
yes
I mean or maybe we just call it graphics
multi-column and that's what it is but I
think it needs to align it needs to work
with I mean I've I never use does
anybody here use multi-column with
graphics
I don't know that I've ever tried it
well let's see what happens
grid with the indicated number of
columns
that's not very flat in the list
oh
okay so if I put in here
let's just do the following let's just
say
I mean if you go to I think I have you
know plants equals your list of arrays
array plots hold on oh I see okay fine
yeah okay great let's do it but but I
was going to just say random Choice here
ah yes
um
okay
seems fine I mean this seems like it did
the right thing I I don't know why the
relative size see this is where we're
goofing up like why did that thing end
up
I see it's matching the width
which is not obviously correct and that
that's again
you know that is a in a sense that's
like this alignment question
and um
am I making sense it's like the
alignment question what are you matching
right do we have a way to specify that
in Grid or in graphics grid what are you
matching
I don't think so
but that would seem useful to me
I mean in a sense that's like outer
boundary matching outer boundary
alignment if we specified outer boundary
alignment
the vertical outer boundary alignment
but not the horizontal outer boundary
alignment then we would be able to
specify this
see what I'm saying
I think that's kind of the way to do it
so what we would say is
um
and maybe we have an association form in
which we say horizontal Arrow vertical
Arrow but we have a list form in which
we and you know by the way another thing
that we really should think about is
fluffing out
the specification of grid options to
allow an association based version
does that make sense
but right now grid options are very
positional and it's kind of hard to deal
with
yes
you know John is commenting
um who could join us on on some
uh
um about can aligning the character most
typically a decimal point but others we
have the alignment marker character to
do this invisibly
that's another good concept I mean that
that the alignment marker thing
um yeah uh can we commit
can we please send um John yeah I just
did that okay
um
okay the alignment marker thing is
another interesting idea
because we could have
we could imagine a just like we'd said
alignment point we can imagine
a
you know
a
alignment
well I don't know it no maybe this is
not so useful
um
yeah
um
okay so here's here's an idea
so let's say that you have a disk
in your in your thing this is a an
object
in the graphic
to be
to be used to define alignment
you see what I'm saying
disc is a little complicated because you
have to say where in the disk but then I
was going to say is it the center of the
disk is this
you're lining up you have to specify it
right you'd have to specify it or you
could give something like the um uh the
same thing that we do for inset where
you're giving the relative position
inside the disk but I mean that makes a
lot more sense to do if it's a point or
a for example okay so if if this was a
graph I can absolutely imagine that you
might have a node that is called that
you know that has an alignment object
wrapper around the vertex name
see what I'm saying
so this is a pseudo-primitive thing not
an option that's correct
because it allows you it's an outside in
Inside Out type thing this is an inside
out
way of specifying something the the
outside in would be to say alignment
Point Arrow this coordinate
right
well that
yeah that's saying from the outside
you're saying from you know rather than
exposing something from the inside of
the graphic to say this is going to be
the alignment you're saying you know
globally
oh I think I mean it's a little bit that
if you give a coordinate position that's
used in user coordinates it's a little
bit not you know not so much from
outside in but scale that's very much
from outside in did John join us I did
yes the yeah and I uh I had a related
example I wanted to send you but I want
to test it out on my system first and I
had a little fumble here on my system
um
uh but concerning the uh your earlier
discussion about uh uh
alignment versus constraints that might
cause something to go crashing off the
side uh
uh Jason Harris did something recently
in Grid which uh and uh I'll just go
ahead and throw the example in chat and
you can try it I'm still installing the
latest version but I think this should
work
I I in any recent 13-2 or or Master
build
uh
at least to suit me and that it worked I
accidentally installed the wrong thing
and I was trying to figure out why it
didn't work and then I realized I
installed the wrong thing so
okay
why is this startup so freaking slow
I'm still clicking look at this there's
nothing on the screen
so we need to look at this I mean it
might be something specific to my system
because of some craziness and startup
but I I think there's a problem
okay because it should never get to that
state where there's nothing on the
screen right
um
well uh on Mac in the startup you should
get bouncing or the bouncing dock icon
until something shows I don't get that I
didn't get that I didn't get it
it needs to be looked at Avery maybe you
can take this and
um I was gonna say the first part of the
startup was it verifying the install I
know I know that okay so this is a this
is alignment
you know it's I mean yeah yeah so
there's there's like a period of and I I
think there's a bug to continue to get
wider but but the point being there's a
period of time when you've given it an
impossible constraints
um yep and
um and so this was something that that
Jason happened to work on recently is
trying to trying to make the impossible
constraint not do something terrible
like push it out of the uh you know out
of the Grid or something like that
right well that's exactly the type of
thing we're talking about and I think I
think it will be a good thing to have an
option
in the graphics case that says how hard
should you try
you know because I was saying before I
think there are cases where there are a
hundred things to line up and one of
them misses
and that's okay it's better than
meticulously because I've I've had many
examples where you know all my Graphics
are tiny because one thing is very tall
yeah yeah right
um well yeah yeah I mean if you have you
know box ratios one and then plot range
you know the it's it goes off in one
particular Dimension yeah right
right Ethan is saying the size of the
frame and access label should be ignored
for alignment well well usually yes but
some you know that's why I was saying we
want this how to align things right what
okay my claim is what we want to do is
to expose for every graphic Okay so
you know what was saying is
you know expose
for every graphic
certain
alignment
uh what are we going to call them
certain alignment what can we say
alignment
um
guides that was what I was just going to
suggest okay all right so certain
alignment guides so they might be and
they will be named
EG
you know frame and each one certain
vertical
vertical and horizontal
alignment guides a frame
an axis I mean a a you know a frame an
axis a principal axis maybe or or a um
uh
maybe an outer axis an outer frame
I mean you're gonna want like left frame
right frame
you know which you know aren't
necessarily going to apply to everybody
no no but but hold on these are these
are going to be left right as well
there's got to be left right top bottom
for all of these
there's the vertical and horizontal you
you want to specify so it's going to be
four guides basically that you're
specifying for everything
okay so you're saying you're saying this
would be
potentially you say left
outer frame
could be a guide name
something like that sure okay all right
so we've got these guides
and
okay so so
um
you know content
would be EG alignment object
and then what we've got to do is say
okay
we are threading together
each one of our things a row a column
whatever it threads together certain you
know
okay sorry each of these is defined
but then the inside the outside in thing
says what should thread together
No actually that's not quite right the
the okay from inside the graphic
it can say
which are the
cons which are the guides that it wants
to be aligned on
I think
question mark oh no no no okay for two
kinds of guides right this is that's
right
too tight
one
it's frame
two
its bounding box
so it should Define
what it considers to be its frame and
what it considers to be its bounding box
does that make sense and usually it will
not lie about its bounding box
although it could lie in order to get
padding or whatever
I we shouldn't call it frame it's not
really frame it's um
it's let's say it's content area
principal content area
right
no but that's not right
no you see that's not right it's it's
it's it's
well it's
ah drat you get what I'm saying it's the
thing that should line up
okay actually
for example if you have a pie chart
with labels going around the outside of
the sectors yeah the labels are not part
of the content area
in many applications right okay hold on
hold on hold on this is the point from
inside the graphic it should say which
guides it wants to be aligned on that's
just one thing okay vertical and
horizontal alignment
okay so then it's defining its vertical
and horizontal alignment
okay
the next question is
okay so it defines its alignment
but then
then it also has a bounding box
and the outer construct
is responsible for making sure that
these bounding boxes don't collide
see what I'm saying so it's gonna try
like an example that um uh that John
gave it's gonna try to just make the
vertical and horizontal alignments work
so so I think the statement you have
above isn't
I don't think that's right so I would
expect that like every graphic would
Define
you know probably relying on defaults in
a lot of cases
what where those alignment guides are
for that graphic
yeah and then the outer thing is the
thing that says I want to align on left
outer frame
and make sure that the bounding boxes
the overall bounding boxes don't collide
so you're saying okay okay I see what
you're saying I see what you're saying
the typical thing will be I made a bunch
of graphics
I did a graphics grid they default
aligned based on bounding boxes
see what I'm saying because that's going
to be the easy default
is a line based on bounding boxes
but then I say oh that looks ugly
because bounding box is safe it's always
going to work
right but it might look stupid because
things you know might be bouncing up and
down okay so then I say okay no I don't
want that kind of alignment I want
um
I see so then you're saying the
convenient thing to do at that moment is
to put a single option into the outer
wrapper
that says actually align these by their
frames for example yes
and then it will just work hopefully
right and your pie chart would you know
potentially
have a way of saying my quote frame no
that's what we're saying about this is
this yeah right and then and then so the
user if they want to so the outer thing
says a line on frames
the user could then re-jigger what
counts as the frame
in in the pie chart for example
correct
so it could Define you know essentially
it this could be something like
alignment rules
or something and it would say you know
Define the axis to be whatever it is
and I don't know there might be named
pieces of the graphic for example
right or something in the plot range
coordinate system or whatever
yeah and some other coordinate system or
this is good we should have figured this
out years ago
think this through this I think this is
a winner this whole general idea I think
this is going to solve the problem of
you know making
essentially nicely aligned arrays of
plots without the you know
inside to outside type stuff
meanwhile I agree with Graphics
multi-column that it's a good idea
I think we need to understand how its
ordering of elements Works relative to
multi-column
because multi-column just goes down
see what I'm saying down the first
column
so this basically wants to be you know
maximal packing or something
um
yeah you see the obvious way for
multi-column to work is the other way
around
if if all the cells are the same size
then the more obvious thing it's kind of
like breadth first of Earth is depth
first so to speak is to go across the
top and then down
so we might need an option for
multi-column or something that might
default differently for graphics perhaps
about what it's it's it's varying from
the name though I mean you know the name
nicely describes what it does you
started with column
and then you turned it into a
multi-column which just breaks the you
know the linear column into multiple
columns fair enough wait wait and you're
saying the Pinterest thing which doesn't
have that ordering shouldn't be called
multi-column
I I believe that to be the case yes or
I'm making yes I'm making that claim
rightly or wrongly I'm making okay so
another possible name for this will be
packed Grid or something
well I don't know that's that's not
that's a mouthful and it only accepts
pector raise no no okay that's a bad
name all right okay
that's that I said can I pack an array
of Graphics okay there's an official
name for this Pinterest thing what is it
the fact that I can't remember it is a
super bad sign
ah I don't think I know it so
we've discussed in a previous meeting
we've both forgotten it
um
uh
masonry layout
that's apparently what it's often called
that's a bizarre yeah I feel like that's
that's not really how you lay bricks
well I mean
it's sideways at least I mean
Christopher you're not thinking you're
thinking of you know the case where the
bricks are all the same shape
right you know there's also the the
thing uh bricks where you have like
rocks the you know different sizes and
yeah yeah yeah yeah The Artisans who
will go through a whole collection
looking for the stone that fits
perfectly yeah yeah right this is a
stone Mason we're thinking Stone Mason
not other you know you need to you know
you know going back well I mean I guess
regular sized bricks go back to like you
know at least the Egyptians but
right this is The Irregular yeah but if
you drive in West Urbana you'll know
that you not everybody has caught up to
this technology yet
Avery suggests pin grid
it's kind of an interesting
I got that from Kristen
I think who got that from Brad
oh okay
I I think that was the original name of
the function that Brett made actually I
don't think I had anything to do with
that
if it was it was just me shortering
Pinterest foreign
but that yeah so why is it pin when you
say pin good it makes it sound like it's
a grid where certain elements are pinned
in place or something yeah because I was
mimicking Pinterest and I didn't want to
type out pictures
so then I just cut it off after three
letters
okay but okay so this
what the heck it's it's really
a column packed grid
it's a pretty weird name Graphics column
packed
maybe it's like a ragged multi-column or
something except that it isn't because
it's a you know it's the breadth first
multi-column
which actually isn't column columnar
what what is the defining the defining
difference between this and multi-column
is multi-column goes down each column
multi-column chops Down The Columns
rather than trying to pack it
whereas this packs it to avoid to
minimize the height
no right right
which I mean yeah but uh maybe something
like column collage because what we're
doing here is similar to image collage
yeah actually I think the word collage
is good because it makes it clear that
that the actual layout is going to be
pretty arbitrary but it will hopefully
look nice
but that is an interesting idea
um
by the way let's talk about how image
collage
relates to any of these constraints so
in a sense Okay so we've got this notion
of you know types of outer wrappers
okay
so we've got
um
uh we've got
row column okay we understand those
we've got grid possibly ragged
possibly ragged but it's still possibly
but possibly ragged but then we've also
got grid
with
um what do we call that in in the grid
case where they're equal
you know where each cell
span span from no no no I'm talking
about
grid
with
you know rows and Road column what are
they called columns equal or something
what is that option
you know what I'm saying okay but
possibly ragged and then there's a
question of you know does the grid
have a height of a of a row
defined locally in that row
or for the whole grid
so I'm saying I mean whether all the
rows are the same height or if they're
different yes yes yes
right that's just one feature of a grid
but what you've already got options for
that in Grid itself but that's going to
come up with the graphics case it's
going to be sometimes you want the rows
to be whatever and sometimes you want
them to be okay
now I mean
the principal difference between
graphics and graphic grid and so on is
that Graphics have fungible
you know total sizes
yes
okay so that's those things then we've
got a pure collage
what is a collage a collage you put
things wherever you feel like right to
just fit them in
the case of image collage does it resize
the elements I think it doesn't right
it does well
maybe it maintains relative sizes no
based on
yes with with weights
right that's the point
I'm saying that it has weights
so that's a good thought the collage is
what we're talking about
because this is a useful concept as well
for for potentially for you know it's
not so common for graphics it's mostly
for images
Graphics are images
no no I know but I mean it's mostly for
things like photographs so you won't do
this
yes probably
I don't absolutely guarantee that but I
like the idea of I think collage is a
good idea for this
calm thing
um
and it could just be Graphics collage
with different
you know with a column method right
right
yeah that's an interesting idea Graphics
collage
where it where it defaults to be
column
Centric
where it where it attempts to maintain
some of the ordering
I don't know where the image collage
attempts to maintain any ordering at all
it doesn't look like it
right
well okay so we need to you know okay so
then the question is
um
you know
how much ordering
is maintained
what is the priority in ordering
now in graphics grid we have this pretty
elaborate optimization thing that's done
to deal with things of weird aspect
ratio
do you know what I'm saying
and that's again relates to the how hard
should you try well I think there's a
question of the okay this is an
interesting question like like
you know
um
it's like how hard should you try
to accommodate
a certain size
um
okay should you ever
clip a graphic
because I can imagine there are cases if
we want to do this properly where the
thing is super tall
and I mean you know one thing you can do
is shrink it down in the vertical
Direction I'll shrink it down all
together right so that it fits its
tallness
another thing you could do is clip it
does that make sense yeah it makes sense
I can't imagine any case where it
wouldn't just annoy people
to do what to clip I don't agree with
you I don't agree with you I think if if
you've got some graphic I mean I've done
this many times you've got some graphic
where the thing is anomalously tall
because you've got aspect ratio to
automatic and you've got a random plot
Point that's sitting out in the middle
of La La Land yep
okay
and it's like oh gosh that one you know
just I can't see anything in that one
because it got too small
because again it's another constraint I
mean we've got another type of
constraint
take a look at image size action
yeah okay right I remember that okay so
another constraint
is image sizes
and image size action is doing some of
the things that you're talking about and
some things that you haven't talked
about
open up the details and you'll see the
list there
hmm
so notice for example the resize the fit
which might actually grow things
right
well this should be generalized I mean
image side this this I agree this is a
good thing
because the scrollable case I can also
imagine being interesting
I hope that should be really cool
in a in a weirdly misfitting Graphics
grid have some things be scorable
um
okay we're gonna have to wrap this
meeting
uh well we got through part of the first
item
now this is a good this this honestly
this conflates with
um the uh
graphic the graphics padding an
alignment meeting that I wanted to have
separately
this the the thing that's driving me
crazy of you know too much space around
certain Graphics they get too small blah
blah blah blah I think this approach
we're talking about here would solve
that because you would simply align on
the frames and you would you know
again
yeah I mean look a different issue Brett
is is buffer space for graphics
because right now every graphic has some
kind of buffer space around it
and some of that
has to do with
uh the wonderful world of the Continuum
so to speak in other words
if the boundary of your graphic is at
coordinate value two
do you slice the point at two in half
right
and or or more to the point if there is
a frame at two
you know what happens to that frame and
this is like closed and open intervals
or some such other thing I don't know
what the right way to think about it is
I mean is there a way to think about it
in terms of closed and open intervals
in other words the in the in the
Continuum so to speak
this Frame could be at exactly
coordinate position two
the problem is you've got two things
you've got the frame is at coordinate
position two and
the bounding
you know the bounding boxes that
coordinate position two question is what
happens in that case
and it feels like it's a little bit like
open sets closed sets whatever is the
boundary
you know
I don't know if there's a good way to
think about it anybody got a thought
about that who's I mean I don't think
I'm going to close sets are quite right
I mean it's more you know are you
allowed to extend a little bit or not
no that's hakalola I mean so we need a
principled way of thinking about that in
in certain contexts we've certainly
supported up to specifications you know
like image size takes it up to
specification for example
right
but that's a don't use it if you don't
have to type story
the question is I mean the sort of the
conundrum here
uh
um
frame and bounding box
at the same coordinate position
right what to do in that case
you know what it reminds me of also it's
like line caps
that makes sense not following okay what
are those what are those things called
form
what's that cat form yeah cap form
okay so in this case right you might not
want the line to ever extend further
than its coordinate position
or you might want to round out at the
end yeah yeah okay
and I can imagine the same type of thing
here that is you've got a point
I don't know I mean
but that's a case where in this case I
know what happens in the bounding box
here if the bounding box of the cap
extends past the bounding box what do
you do
um I believe that's part of the plot
range padding Brett may correct me if
I'm wrong
well I mean if you have I mean it would
probably be more image padding if
anything but okay but I think you had
him get thick enough lines
look the point is there's no symbolic
setting for padding
yeah I mean in general this is the same
sort of problem as you know I mean Plata
sine wave with a really thick line and
you're gonna have to have more space
around it not to chop off that line you
know
you know plot style goes to 30 or
absolute thickness of 30. absolute
thickness or thickness no not thickness
of 30. thickness of 30 I'll just give
you a big uh Black Box
yeah see look at that hack of you know
that horror up there
that's some line segments that did weird
things
now if I if I put in here but uh but but
note also that you know I mean we did a
good enough job that if you hadn't made
it so ridiculously thick it would still
fit oh yeah
now if I say cap form Round Here
that's interesting
I mean at some extent that's a Max
specific thing
you know for various performance reasons
yeah I understand that but look at the
way this is chopped at the top
like that's an issue right and cat form
would have no impact on that right I
mean we see the effect of the cat form
on the side on the side I see what
you're saying okay but the chopping you
see this is a case where we don't know
this is a case where the padding is kind
of just a hack just a heuristic
because the truth is
the
this is an interesting case because this
the the bounding box
defined by all the actual ink and the
content elements
is bigger than the bounding box defined
by the coordinate system well okay now
set plot range clipping goes to false
so it's a little bit different uh around
the zero zero
oh so it is
all right we need can we get a separate
custom meeting about all this stuff
about you know Graphics alignment
Graphics clipping
Etc please
and with plot range clipping false once
you specify enough image padding then
everything comes in
so if you like add to that image padding
10 you know that will be enough then
isn't that a lot of image creating
is that I think for example Brad here
has been working on a lot of detailed
Graphics stuff and I bet he doesn't know
about these options like I don't
remember these options I sort of vaguely
remember us putting them in
yes sorry I don't know all the options
in one area where I have problem every
time I try to do it is if there's an
icon that's embedded as a graph node
because the graphics will often have a
lot of extra space around the outside
and then it causes the edges
um the arrows that go to the edges yeah
the arrows to not come into the right
place they look like they're too short
but it only looks like it's too short
because you can't see that's a good
example of where you really want a a
proper shrink wrapped bounding box is
when the things going to be used as a
node in a graph well is that what is
shrink wrap the is the correct option to
set
no because that's a 3D Graphics option
well and and also uh is there an option
like image padding I mean is there
something Brad can actually do
here well Nick Nick told me one the
other day that was like um
something about padding that I tried to
set it and I guess that that wasn't the
magic option
but I I think I've talked to Charles
about this too who says that I think he
told me there is a magic option that
fixes everything and it makes the
vertexes look good when they're embedded
in the graph
right hey I've I've got to run off here
in fact I'm doing another live stream in
a few minutes
um let's get a custom meeting about this
this collection topics okay and then we
continue on the pay maybe not so you
know the higher coconuts later
no they're not a coconuts fruit yes they
are
I think they're you have seeds
what
I guess if they don't have seeds
uh because we were about to say
something and then I'm going to learn
something about coconuts and then we'll
go
no I was just saying I think coconuts
are nuts oh yeah that does make some
sense
um they are a seed yes yeah yes the all
right okay see you guys later yeah bye
for now